die morgenröte des vertrauens habe sich
gezeigt so blumig umschrieb präsident
putin das treffen mit präsident biden
es war ein historischer tag heute in
genf eine konstruktive annäherung
zwischen russland und den usa
die botschafter werden wieder in beide
länder zurückgeschickt das heißt man ist
weiterhin zum gespräch bereit auch über
viele strittige themen
menschenrechtsverletzungen die ukraine
cyberattacken beiden trifft putin ende
der eiszeit unser thema in der phoenix
runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
auf diesen handschlag hatte die welt
gewartet heute mittag am neutralen ort
in der schweiz
danach hat man knapp vier stunden
miteinander gesprochen es geht nichts
über ein persönliches gespräch so joseph
biden wir haben nur 45 minuten ich
begrüße sie herzlich zur phoenix runde
und darf ich meine gäste vorstellen
kessing us- profis bei uns deutsch
amerikanische politikwissenschaftlerin
und seit gestern neue direktorin der
deutschen gesellschaft für auswärtige
politik der gap also frisch aus habe zu
uns gekommen da hat sie lange zu
konfliktforschung und diplomatie gelehrt
und geforscht
herzlich willkommen ich begrüße hubert
seipel journalist und filmemacher und
für die ard hat er die dokumentation ich
putin gedreht und jetzt ist gerade sein
neues buch erschien putins macht warum
europa russland braucht und dann kommen
wir direkt zu europa denn zugeschaltet
in brüssel ist sonst thomas kutschker er
ist politischer korrespondent der faz
für die europäische union die nato und
die benelux-staaten hatte eine sehr
arbeitsreiche woche herzlich willkommen
und den grandiosen abend in genf ist uns
für begabt zugeschaltet sie ist die
moskau korrespondentin des zdf gut nahm
frau gar ich weiß nicht ob sie uns schon
hören wäre ich höre nämlich jetzt schon
stimmen aus genf hallo frau gaga wir
haben wir haben gerade ein bisschen noch
ein paar problemchen mit der leitung
nach kämpft das ist ja klar an einem tag
wo die ganze welt von dort schaltet
beginnen wir hier einmal es geht um die
atmosphäre beginnen wir damit mal
facebook beide präsidenten haben sich
erst mal ganz nett begrüßt und danach
hatte man das geschulte sind eigentlich
ganz zufrieden aber beide eine getrennte
pressekonferenz allerdings abgehalten
was war ihr eindruck
es war ein arbeitsgespräch und es waren
arbeitsgespräche auf neutralem boden wie
sie das schon betont haben
natürlich ist nichts in dieser
klein taktung der diplomatie einfach so
gewählt inklusive der personen die bei
den unterschiedlichen meetings dabei
waren aus diesen ging auch ganz klar
eine signalwirkung hervor
also was wollten beide parteien an
diesem tisch und was wollten sie auch in
dem kleinen gespräch also noch mal den
vergleich zu dem gespräch in helsinki
zwischen präsident trump und dem
russischen präsidenten
da wurde unter vier augen geredet was
natürlich viele experten für hoch
gefährlich hielten
und wir erinnern uns noch an diese
unsägliche pressekonferenz wo der
amerikanische präsident quasi vorgeführt
wurde da hat präsident biden von
vornherein gesagt wir legen einen ganz
anderen stil an den tag
wir kommunizieren unterschiedlich und so
konnte jeder für sich in seiner eigenen
semantik die erfolge und es gab ja
substanzielle punkte die abgearbeitet
wurden dann auch in ihrem entsprechenden
duktus verkaufen also das war hohes
diplomatisches theater aber glaube ich
dort noch für beide seiten für den
moment erfolgreichen und könnte im bild
des theaters bleibt haben auch beide
ihre hauptrolle spielen können oder ist
einer sozusagen zum nebendarsteller
degradiert wurden nein und das war eben
das ganz interessante also wir haben
jetzt nicht den george hw bush moment
gehabt mit ich habe tief in putins augen
geguckt und die seele des mannes erkannt
oder umgekehrt nicht ebenso diese im
grund genommen gefolgschaft des
amerikanischen präsidenten gegenüber
russland sondern da hat man den profi
joe biden gesehen sehr ausgeklügelte
diplomatie das macht der mann seit
jahrzehnten und also insofern es war
fein inszeniert und es kann jeder zu
seinem wort ich höre die leitung steht
nach dem schon guten abend für gegart
zdf korrespondentin sonst in moskau
wir haben hier kurz angesprochen über
beiden und das hohe diplomatische kunst
stück was dahintersteht
jetzt sind schon ein paar stunden
vergangen was ist ihr hauptsächlich oder
der wichtigste eindruck auch gerade mit
dem blick auf putin von diesem treffen
also ich war vorhin bei der
pressekonferenz von präsident putin
dabei und ich habe einen sehr gelöst
wirkende präsidenten erlebt der zu
scherzen aufgelegt war und der aber auch
keine gelegenheit eigentlich ausgelassen
hat seine position noch mal zu
verteidigen die position hatten sich
nicht grundlegend geändert zu dem was er
vor dem gipfel gesagt hat und er hat
auch schon ganz ordentlich gegen die usa
eigentlich ausgeteilt muss man sagen
also um jetzt mal ein beispiel zu nennen
zum beispiel wurde er gefragt ob es denn
zur sprache gekommen sei in seinem
gespräch mit joe biden die repressionen
gegen die gruppe die oppositionellen in
russland und darauf ist präsident putin
gar nicht groß eingegangen sondern hat
dann eigentlich eher so was gesagt wie
da müsste doch die usa erst mal vor
ihrer eigenen haustür kehren und hat
dann quasi an gespielt auf die 400
menschen die das capitol gestürmt haben
hat versucht das gleichzusetzen mit zum
beispiel den protesten die alexej
nawalny organisiert hat da kommen wir
gleich noch so haben wir auch gleich
rote und so aber im großen und ganzen
sagen wie auch das ist ein gelungenes
treffen gewesen
von allen seiten wurde man dass das kann
man das so sagen
also mein eindruck ist schon dass das
auf jeden fall ein gelungenes treffen
für präsident putin war er hat seine
positionen klar machen können
er wurde natürlich auch danach gefragt
ob denn joe biden seine roten linien ihm
klar gemacht hätte und könnte putin hat
dann schon gesagt ja dass das war so und
die haben wir auch alle miteinander
verstanden
er sagte dann aber später und das fand
ich ganz interessant dass weder die
russische delegation noch die
amerikanische delegation in irgendeiner
art und weise druck ausgeübt haben und
das lässt mich dann doch wieder so ein
bisschen denken im umkehrschluss kann
das ja auch bedeuten dass er eben keinen
druck keine klare kante sozusagen
wahrgenommen hat von dem was von joe
biden ausgeben kann vielleicht doch
später kommen her seit wir haben sie es
empfunden und die tatsache dass das ist
überhaupt dieses treffen kam wie wichtig
war dass man die beziehung war ziemlich
unten ich glaube weiter runter gehen sie
gar nicht mehr in dem zusammenhang die
beiden botschafter der amerikanische und
der russische waren nicht mehr in der
jeweiligen hauptstadt was ihren job ist
um den alltag einfach mal zu
organisieren um normale kommunikation zu
ermöglichen konsulate waren dicht
gemacht worden mitarbeiter waren
entlassen worden auf beiden seiten also
wo sollte das eigentlich jetzt noch
enden das war glaube ich so der punkt
der zweite punkt es war natürlich eine
sorgfältige inszenierung und da gebe ich
ihnen gerne recht in dem zusammenhang
aber ich hab den kunden wissen wo anders
gesehen
ich war damals dort vor ort ich war eine
eltern gehe ich war auch bei der
pressekonferenz dabei eben die
pressekonferenz war gesplittert war gab
es nur 200 hängen dastehende und 5000
irgendwo anders gleich zeichner
ich habe noch nie eine pressekonferenz
gesehen wo journalisten und das nie um
die amerikanischen das verhältnis
zwischen trump und den journalisten dann
natürlich total kaputt ist wo die den
schon fast angebot allerdings sagen dass
das nicht sagen wir mal dass das geht
ich habe das noch nie erlebt wie zwei
präsidenten zusammen standen putin hat
sich das natürlich cool angebot in dem
zusammenhang weil es bei seinen
heimvorteil in was die anderen
veranstaltet haben und ich glaube so
dass man getrennte preisaktion ist
diesmal wollte man nicht haben zwar auf
beiden seiten aber auf einmal beide
wollten dass das im grunde genommen doch
schon mal ein anfang wieder wird
der coach hat dieser ist dieser gipfel
heute in genf war ist steht am ende
einer reise von beiden wo er ganz klar
noch mal betont hat oder gezeigt hat wie
wichtig europa für amerika ist das
sozusagen europa auch ein bisschen mit
heute damit neben biden bei putin oder
war das dann doch ganz klar usa und
russland das war beides ziel er hat ja
diesen termin ans ende seiner reise
gelegt er wollte auftreten als das hat
er heute übrigens auch gesagt der
repräsentant des westens mit einem
mandat wenn man so will der nato der eu
der g7 der westlichen demokratien um
eine geschlossene haltung gegenüber
putin vertreten zu können so und das war
die dramaturgie dieser woche und
zweifellos hat er vorher ja dafür
gesorgt dass eine gewisse
geschlossenheit herrscht dass auch das
signal des aufbruchs
deutlich wurde dass also ein bruch mit
der ära seines vorgängers vollzogen ist
auch wenn das gehört eben zur wahrheit
dazu ein solcher brocken er sich nicht
so ohne weiteres reparieren lässt das
haben wir gesehen
bei den streitfragen die noch die
beziehungen zur eu belasten stelle
insbesondere die sind eben immer noch in
kraft von trump eingesetzt und auch bei
der nato gibt es natürlich ein paar
dissonanzen wir haben da einen
präsidenten der ja im wesentlichen china
als größte strategische herausforderung
sieht was verständlich ist wenn man das
ding um globale vormachtstellung nimmt
dann ist natürlich für die amerikaner
china das wichtigste land aber die nato
ist eine im nordatlantik gebunden ist
und aus sicht dieses bündnisses ist eben
russland
die größte gefahr das ist diese woche
auch zum ausdruck gekommen
von den socken spannt sich ein bogen von
dem besuch bei der nato auch zu diesem
treffen hingehen
wir schauen mal danach wie beide
präsidenten
heute darüber gesprochen wie die
atmosphäre eigentlich war haben wir
einen kurzen ausschnitt wir beginnen mit
vladimir putin
ich glaube dass wir insgesamt die
gleiche sprache gesprochen haben
das bedeutet aber nicht dass wir
einander in die seele oder in die augen
schauen müssen und ewige liebe und
freundschaft schwören müssen nein wir
verteidigen die interessen unserer
völker und unser länder und solche
beziehungen haben sind immer pragmatisch
der ton des gesamten treffens von 04
stunden war eigentlich gut positioniert
es hat keine schrillen aspekte dabei
gegeben
die waren verschiedene meinungen in
ihren bereich haben das jeweils gewirkt
aber das ist ja nichts überladener
atmosphäre erfolgsjahr das nicht
übertrieben
wir sind ruhig geblieben also putin
spricht etwas blumiger es gesagt das ist
nicht die ewige liebe hat ja verfolgende
morgenröte des vertrauens gesprochen
biden hat später wenn man wirklich um
vertrauen es geht ganz klar um
eigeninteressen also das ist so ein
bisschen ja wir haben finden sie das
wenn wir das so hören ja das würde schon
ein bruch mit der amerikanischen politik
ja also wenn wir uns angucken wie bill
clinton angesetzt hat damals so die
transformations- bewegungen gegenüber
russland oder wenn wir darüber
nachdenken dass obama quasi noch den
reset-knopf gedrückt hat ja und wirklich
noch davon ausgegangen ist dass herr
putin als rationaler internationaler
akteur einzustufen wäre sehen wir doch
jetzt hat dann auch gesagt rosa ist eine
regionalmacht ja ja aber der der ansatz
war zu sagen wir müssen das ganze
verhältnis neu denken bei bonn dennoch
immer noch irgendwie schauen wollen
russland ins boot holen zu können
das auto beiden jetzt nicht mehr das ist
ganz das sind viel klarere ganz gezielte
strategische punkte mit der diese
amerikanische präsident da hinkommt
erwartet auch keinen noch keine keine
feier oder keine oder keine romantische
abendessen zusammen genau aber das ist
auch david da geht es eben noch mal um
die ganz starke diplomatische
sequenzierung und die bilder man kann
nicht einem mann völkerrechts vergehen
in der ukraine
richtigerweise vorwerfen und dann brot
zusammenbrechen
wir denken an die religiöse symbolik des
brot brechen und so weiter und so fort
das haben die amerikaner von vornherein
ausgeschlossen also dass das war die
größere aussage ist das ist jetzt ein
klarer realpolitischer blick auf
russland wir sagen erst mal das was herr
putin hören muss nämlich dass er eine
großmacht ist es braucht herr putin für
sein seelenheil und dann sagen wir
umgekehrt aber hier sind dann unsere
roten linien die machen wir klar und wir
planen ganz strategisch was dann die
konsequenzen sein könnten das
artikulieren wir in einer
pressekonferenz wie der heutigen nicht
ganz deutlich aber wir haben einen plan
und wir gehen davon aus wir geben eben
den rationalen vorlauf also wir sagen
wir gucken paar monate in die zukunft
was könnte da gehen aber wir wissen auch
ganz genau
nicht erst seit der rede 2007 auf der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz
herr putin ist nicht unbedingt als
rationaler akteurin auf der
internationalen bühne bekannt also wir
treffen jetzt immer so dass über die usa
den ton angeben und bestimmen wo es lang
geht ist es ist das so heißt oder wie
mächtig sehen sie denn gut und ich finde
es wunderbar sie beschrieben haben weil
sie haben eigentlich nur eine
inszenierung beschrieben die
grundlegenden unterschied war eigentlich
schon in den 2000 an die waren natürlich
ganz massiv auch von der geopolitik da
und sie waren natürlich auch gar nicht
in einem harmonischen verhältnissen mit
obama in dem zweiten zusammenzufinden
insofern finde ich diese diplomatische
ableitung schön aber nicht so ganz
zutreffend weil die kontroversen standen
immer und sie standen immer ganz massiv
und fest ich werde 2011 nehmen sie mal
die kleinigkeit von libyen her dass uns
dieses desaster ein gefragt hat
gleichzeitig die amerikaner libyen platt
gemacht haben syrien will ich auch
nochmal ansprechen dem zusammenhang das
war auch eine mittlere katastrophe das
ist nicht einfach so passiert sondern
wegen des irak-krieges wenn sie sich
noch erinnern abu ghraib sagt ihnen
vielleicht noch was da ging es um
konkrete geopolitische größenordnung
also die vorstellung dass die sich nur
nicht richtig benommen haben und keine
wirklichen massiven gegensätze mehr
hatten wir wollen von der nato arbeiter
und gar nicht mehr sprechen
wie kann ich so nicht so unbedingt
polzin jetzt ist es gebe ich auch gerade
sie dagegen komplett recht aber es geht
jetzt darum wie macht man in der
sequenzierung weiter es geht gar nicht
mehr an der seite wissen sie warum tue
ich mir das noch dazu sagen es gibt es
gibt zwei riesen probleme amerika ist
gespalten durch die trump wähler und
durch einen breiten die haben
riesenprobleme zu hause die leute sind
sich ja nicht näher gekommen sie haben
zwei herren beiden gewählt und der
zweite punkt ist amerika hat china vor
der tür in china bedeutet für amerika
eine gigantische herausforderung und es
gibt die nato die nato möchte auch nicht
mehr unbedingt wenn sie noch marco
erinnern als politischer dienstleister
für amerikanische geopolitik erhalten
also wollen sie die nato nach china
schicken in dem zusammenhang es gibt
kein einziges asiatisches mitglieder
sowie ein bisschen das sind so viele
themen nochmals hin zu sortieren ich
wollte ganz gerne mal fragen waldfrau
sie sind ja sonst korrespondentin in
moskau wie wichtig war dieses treffen
für putin innenpolitisch in russland
also wie wurde heute darüber berichtet
es gab auf der pressekonferenz der
sowohl kollegen aus russland als auch
internationale kollegen was war da ihr
eindruck wie wichtig war dieses treffen
für putin in russland
ich glaube dass dieser preis ist gar
nicht zu benennen für präsident putin
war das extrem wichtig für ihn war es
auch wichtig dass dieser gipfel von
beiden initiiert wurde das gibt ja nicht
wenige stimmen die sagen das war
überhaupt der grund warum er mit diesen
truppenaufmarsch in der nähe der ukraine
begonnen hat um sozusagen darzustellen
dass er eine ernsthafte bedrohung sein
kann und das hat dazu geführt dass
präsident biden bei ihm angerufen hat
und der folge gab es heute diesen gipfel
also insofern das war sehr wichtig für
ihn und ich denke dass die die nachricht
oder die botschaft die präsident putin
senden will auch natürlich in diesem
wahljahr aber auch ganz generell viel
stärker innenpolitisch ist als als
vielleicht außenpolitisch ich denke dass
auch präsident putin war ist dass der
zug irgendwie mal wieder zu g7
eingeladen zu werden und so war der
erste moment abgefahren darum geht es
nicht es geht nicht darum sich als
jemand zu präsentieren der ein echter
partner sein kann sondern es geht darum
sich zu präsentieren als ein starkes
gegenüber als jemand der eben ernst zu
dem ist und vor allem für das eigene
publikum für die großen für das
russische volk jeden zweifel nicht
aufkommen keine zweifel aufkommen zu
lassen dass es womöglich jemanden geben
könnte der russlands geschicke besser
lenkt als präsident putin für putin ist
es wichtig zu sagen schaut her ich bin
derjenige bei dem die staatenlenker
anrufen wenn sie was zu besprechen haben
hier aus der russischen elite muss
keiner auf die idee kommen mir meinen
platz streitig zu machen
ein guter wie sieht das denn die eu wie
schaut die output ihnen auf russland
auch da gibt es ja natürlich durchaus
unterschiedliche ansätze je nachdem er
auf welches land man da schaut also
irgendwie hat das vielleicht auch putin
standing sozusagen gegenüber der eu
erhöht also wir haben heute ja eine
etwas neue situation weil die eu eine
eigene strategie präsentiert hat das ist
noch nicht von den staats und
regierungschefs besprochen und
angenommen aber das fußt auf der letzten
debatte die sibe russland hatten
der außenbeauftragte borel hat das
vorgestellt und sein ausblick ist
eindeutig negativ und pessimistisch die
diagnose lautet man befindet sich in
einer abwärtsspirale in den beziehungen
und muss sich realistischerweise auf
weitere rückschläge einstellen und das
heißt dann in der konsequenz dass die eu
zwar weiter versuchen will
bei einzelnen fragen mit russland im
gespräch zu bleiben oder überhaupt erst
ins gespräch zu kommen
im wesentlichen sie aber ihren
sanktionskurs verschärfen wird heute
dieses papier enthält die klagedrohung
dass man die russische regierung die
finanziellen ressourcen der russischen
regierung einschränken will
die sie die sie braucht um ihre
aggressive außenpolitik weiterzuführen
und da ist natürlich ein hebel der für
putin sehr gefährlich werden kann
und insofern besteht hier zwischen den
amerikanern und den europäern doch auch
einen schulterschluss also ein klarer
schulterschluss was aber ja schwierig
ist weil wir brauchen hier auch die
guten beziehungen zu russland hebbel
würden sie wie empfinden sie das wie die
eu sich jetzt diese strategie so
gegenüber russland die sich jetzt
aufgegeben hat also auch zurückdrängen
das ist ein bisschen problematisch weil
sie können konflikte nicht mit
sanktionen auf dauer lösen
das funktioniert schlicht und ergreifend
nicht wenn sie den ukraine konflikt
neben beispielsweise da gibt es das noch
mal die firma die versuchen seit jahren
voran zu kommen um die minsk zu erfüllen
sie waren 2009/10 schon relativ weit im
dezember 2009 10 hatten sie monatelang
vor verhandelt also sich getroffen
hatten makro merkel putin und der neue
präsident selensky das eigentlich die
demarkationslinie 400 kilometer lang
frei geräumt wird gleichzeitig nochmal
zielinski hat es damals abgelehnt sie
dann alle überraschend ist fast vom
hocker gefallen damals und
einzelgespräche mit ihm
warum weil der druck in der ukraine so
hoch ist weil die splittung in der
ukraine wiederum so hoch ist und da
kommen wir zum prinzipiellen problem
wir brauchen russland schon deswegen
weil diese wunden die geschlagen worden
sind zwischen den ehemaligen
sowjetrepubliken zwischen russland nicht
verheilen werden auf dieser
kriegerischen basis denn wenn sie sich
nur noch mit schrecken sozusagen über
die ist an die historie in sinnen kommen
sie einfach keinen schritt weiter und
das ewige sanktionen sanktionen nimmt
man das am besten verleihen an russland
hört uns keinen schritt weiter weil es
auch innerhalb russlands sozusagen eine
trotzreaktion her beruft den geht schon
durchaus schlecht wegen der sanktionen
überhaupt gar keine frage nur das bringt
die heute eher zu gehen
putin ist ja nicht so ganz isoliert in
russland hat die letzten wahlen mit 77
prozent gebunden
auch außenputz league kommen wir da raus
aus dieser falle sehr gut gab er hat ja
große angst vor seinen gegnern hört das
scharfe vorgehen gegen die opposition
gegen herrn aber all das sind doch
zeichen dafür dass putin sich seiner
macht nicht sicher ist so wie er regiert
im moment hat er angst vor der
demokratie verlangt vor seiner eigenen
gesellschaft war seine eigenen
zivilgesellschaft und insofern glaube
ich nicht dass man dass man sein
verhalten belohnen
wichtig ist natürlich dass man immer
wenn man ein zeichen an russland sendete
unterscheidet zwischen der regierung und
dem land und der bevölkerung seit 20
jahren nachrufe über putin und die
bevölkerung leidet natürlich unter den
sanktionen aber da sie das stichwort nur
weil sie gerade genannt haben das war
natürlich auch thema und überhaupt der
opposition und die
menschenrechtsverletzungen
dazu wollen wir auch nochmal kurzen o
ton hören wir beginnen mit beiden und
putin spricht auch über navalny aber
putin sagt die den namen navalny also
nur einige oppositionspolitiker der in
haft sitzt und jetzt hören wir mal
wieder darüber gesprochen wurde
das habe ich es könnte putin deutlich
gemacht und deshalb bringen wir unsere
sorgen wie zum beispiel in vallendar war
nie so zum ausdruck das habe ich
präsident putin deutlich gemacht wie
werden fragen der grund- und
menschenrechte immer wieder
thematisieren denn so sind wir die
forderung des gesetzes ignoriert er
wusste dass alles kam nach russland und
ich glaube ganz bewusst war bereit
festgenommen zu werden das heißt er hat
das erreicht und das will was er wollte
also ganz unterschiedliche ansätze zum
thema navalny wie wichtig ist das ein
symbol
navalny um druck auszuüben für russland
oder wie wichtig ist es ihnen sind in
den usa dieser fall also ich glaube das
ganze thema menschenrechte und die
ganzen grundprinzipien dafür wofür steht
demokratie noch die wir haben gesehen
dass die ganze reise unter dem schirm
war was ist demokratie im 21 jahrhundert
also der schulterschluss den heimischen
ansprach also
wiederum die sequenzierung immer diesen
schulterschluss zu suchen denn herr
putin hat sich aufgeschwungen der zahl
der liberalen demokratien zu werden also
und damit nachhaltig zu versuchen europa
nach ihnen zu spalten und zu schwächen
das heißt das war jetzt die konnte auf
härte der amerikaner das machen sie
natürlich auch der menschenrechts duktus
unter herr beiden hat einen ganz anderen
schlag eingenommen als unter donald
trump auch gegenüber china
also das ist ein grundbestandteil des
verständnisses von westlicher demokratie
das heißt wenn herrn wenn es neuwahlen
geben was passieren würde würden das
auch wirkliche konsequenzen haben das
hat bei der seite genau das wollte ich
da sagen das hat herr beiden auch noch
mal betont und jetzt nochmal zu dem
thema sanktionen
sanktionen sind ein sich enger ziehen
der kreis und die eu hat nachgeliefert
im sinne der amerikaner im dezember des
letzten jahres
magnitski act sanktionen also de facto
sanktionen die man auf menschen
rechtsgrundlage dann eben entsprechend
immer enger ziehen kann das ist ein sehr
ausgewogenes ballett weil man mal
sanktionen ist es ja auch beim iran
immer genau schauen muss welche anderen
konsequenzen kann es da geben aber der
strick um den engeren kreis des herrn
putin das kann sich noch durchaus viel
enger ziehen und das wissen wir auch und
mit diesen gebärden also sind nicht nur
gebärden sondern es hat auch
funktionelle dimensionen
umgekehrt muss aber dann irgendwann der
westen auch klarstellen da bin ich dann
auch vielleicht bei ihnen herr seidel
unter welchen bedingungen sanktionen
zurückgenommen werden könnten aber
solange die völker rechtsverletzung mit
der annexion der krim und gerade den den
verhältnis in der ukraine und dann jetzt
natürlich auch dem einwirken auf den bus
im raum steht wird das einfach nicht
passieren so und das heißt in dem
diplomatischen thulke dingern sagen
würde ist das spielen die sanktionen
immer noch eine große rolle
frau gabi wurde es wurde heute mehrfach
in der pressekonferenz gerade auch von
amerikanischen journalisten danach
gefragt wie sehr berührt dass putin der
weniger diesen den namen gar nicht
ausspricht also ist das ein punkt wo er
sich wirklich ärgert oder woher also die
die muss man das einschätzen
ich glaube er ist über diesen punkt wo
er sich darüber ärgert dass er darauf
angesprochen wird mittlerweile hinaus
also er antwortet darauf eigentlich sehr
routiniert mit den immer gleichen man
kann schon sagen satz bausteinen also
dass alexej nawalny eben jemand sei der
das russische recht gebrochen habe dem
das bewusst gewesen seid ihr dann wegen
gesundheitlicher probleme nach
deutschland ausgereist sein und sich
trotzdem entschlossen habe zurück nach
russland zu kommen das ist schon sehr
diese antworten sind sehr vorgefertigt
ich glaube das überrascht ihn nicht wenn
er da immer wieder darauf angesprochen
wird und da lässt er sich auch nicht aus
der reserve locken da hat er seine
position gefunden und die wird er auch
öffentlich immer genauso weiter
bestätigen
er würde gerne nochmal auf diesen
begriff menschenrechte welt
menschenrechte ist werde ich zu
bedeutend um sie einfach nur politisch
verwenden zu können
denn sinn sich noch wann die
unabhängigkeitserklärung der vereinigten
staaten war 17 76 und dass jeder mensch
gleich ist wissen sie wann der 44
präsident der amerikaner gewählt worden
ist obama das war ein paar jahrhunderte
später wissen sie wie viel schwarz
amerikaner in amerikanischen
gefängnissen sitzen 33 prozent von
100000 sie haben nur zwölf prozent der
bevölkerung also wenn wir darüber
sprechen ob wir menschenrechte bei uns
einhalten wenn ich das schon mal ganz
wichtig wenn wir sie nur noch als waffe
nach außen richten gleichzeitig noch mal
parallel kriege als sie heute auch
angefangen hat die blätter wurde auf die
sanktionen wir haben ja noch keine
sanktionen deswegen was die amerikaner
angehen würde
sozusagen als umgekehrt ist beispiel gab
es irgendeine sanktion für den irakkrieg
von 100000 ihr leben gelassen haben weil
die amerikaner effekt haben und falsche
behauptung auf der wir haben immer nur
das eine bild den feind gegen den wir im
zweifelsfall den strick wie sie vorhin
so schön gesagt haben rom ziehen müssen
weil er das böse für uns darstellt war
nicht so ist wie wir und das ist ein
problem vor allem bei russland mit der
äquidistanz äquidistanz sehr vorsichtig
menschenrechte oder dass ich schon
was er sich eine evolution unterzieht
dass es in westlichen demokratien im
weitesten sinne gedacht so natürlich
also wenn wir jetzt auf die gründung
amerikas zurückgehen dann verstanden
seda menschen unter weißen landbesitzern
und neben nicht unter einer schwarzen
versklavten bevölkerung etc
da brauchen ganz kuba streiten oder
diskutieren doch jetzt ist es ja
wirklich so dass eben modernen
verständnis der amerikanischen menschen
rechnung umgekehrt sieht man das jetzt
auch in der art und weise wie herr
beiden zuhause aufräumen möchte also es
ist ja er geht ja nicht und das hat er
auch noch mal am anfang der
pressekonferenz gesagt amerika ist ein
gedanke ist ein ideologie und das ist
eine eine eine entwicklung die sich
immer weiter denkt denn das ist das
moderne demokratieverständnis von
amerika so und er hat gesagt das ist gut
es ist eben nicht statisch und das
entspricht das ist ein entgegen dass es
diametral entgegengesetzt zu den
menschen bild was herr putin hat was
herr putin für sich und sein land
vertritt das ist eben dass die liberale
orthodoxe geschlossene bestimmte regel
kataloge einhalten und so weiter und so
fort
und da haben sie beide noch mal wirklich
ganz klar gemacht wo ihre ideologischen
unterschiede sind sie sind eben doch und
nahkämpfe brauchen das wort kalter krieg
nicht im mund nehmen aber es sind eben
doch die großen ideologischen gräben in
dieser evolution von menschen
verständnis die sind ganz klar da und
die amerikaner
er hat das ganz klar gemacht heute das
sieht er auch so amerika entwickelt sich
und amerika ist nie in dem sinne fertig
und sie sind im besitz von 90 prozent
der atomwaffen beide länder zusammen als
man da ist es hier ein wert an sich
natürlich dass ihr besprechen und frau
da wollten sie sich wollten sie dazu
etwas sagen
ich wollte noch eine noch eine kurze
anmerkung dazu ich denke es gibt noch
weitere unterschiede nämlich im fall von
alexander wahlen ist es so der mann
wurde mit einem international geächteten
nervengift vergiftet ich denke da hat
die internationale gemeinschaft dann
auch durchaus das recht eine aufklärung
zu fordern und da kommt eben nichts von
russischer seite
es ist auch so dass russland
völkerrechts
widrige dinge außerhalb seines eigenes
landes regiert im tiergarten ist ein
mensch erschossen worden
das deutet viel darauf hin dass das
sozusagen aus russland gelenkt war die
steeples in großbritannien vergiftet
wurden auch da viele spuren die nach
russland führen ich denke das ist doch
ein ganz großer unterschied und der
berechtigt dazu dass daneben auch die
usa oder europa von russland erklärungen
fordern
ich würd nutzer haben wird es jetzt ganz
massive ja ich finde schon wichtig weil
hier ist glaube ich gerade ein
unterstützer sicher was die kollegin
gesagt hat aber was ja ein zeitbild
gesagt hat das ist eben die strategie
von putin alles mit reifen äpfel und
birnen zu vergleichen und zu sagen also
weil es probleme und echte defizite gibt
in demokratischen gesellschaften steht
das auf einer ebene mit dem was er macht
das ist natürlich überhaupt nicht der
fall
man kann das ganze jahr weiterführen wir
haben gravierende cyber-angriffen
russischen ministerium das erlebt auf
den bundestag wir haben die einmischung
und manipulation der amerikanischen
präsidenten wahl erlebt ein ähnlicher
versuch ist in frankreich unternommen
worden und erst vor ein paar tagen ist
das amerikanische pipelinenetz nahezu
zusammengebrochen
derweil einen angriff nach dem mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit weissrussland und
zwar vom russischen auslandsgeheimdienst
gerichtet auf dieses partnernetz
einfachen verübt wurde
das ist kein konventioneller krieg den
wir da sehen aber das ist eine form des
krieges und heute war das wichtigste für
joe biden hier eine rote linie zu ziehen
das sehr klar in der pressekonferenz
gesagt amerika wird das nicht länger
hinnehmen er hat gut in eine liste
gegeben mit 16 sektoren die amerika wo
amerika ist nicht akzeptieren wird
das dort cyberangriffe vorgenommen
werden
oder hat ihm auch klagen gesagt und zwar
ich glaube so klar wie das nun möglich
ist in einem solchen gespräch
wenn er sich daran nicht hält wird
amerika solcher angriff
abwehren und vergessen biden hat auch
gesagt die usa haben beachtliche cyber
techniken hat gehört das weiß putin
und das letzte was er sich wünschen
würde wäre ein kalter krieg weil das
wäre ja vielleicht wieder die gefahr
putin hat dagegen gesagt also das ist
also die cyber-attacken die meisten
kommen aus den usa sagt dass der
abgewehrt natürlich schon den punkt wenn
sie sich noch an frau ein erstes mal an
haben snowden erinnern wer relativ klar
und deutlich aufgezeigt hat dass die nsa
mit 40.000 mitarbeitern 11 milliarden
haushaltsmittel mit der größte hacker
und im grunde genommen überwacher ist
das handy von frau merkel ist noch ein
bester erinnerung glaube ich noch mal
und der zweite punkt ich weiß nicht ob
sie noch den muller bericht in
erinnerung haben der gesagt hat weil ja
auch immer davon ausgegangen ist herr
trump ist sozusagen von herb trump ist
von das ist eigentlich eingesetzt
bedauerlicherweise in seine zweijährigen
untersuchungen festgestellt dass dem
nicht so ist und es keine verschwörung
gibt dass sie glauben nicht dass es
seine attacken gibt es muss alba hat der
russische hacker ist sehr guter
genetischer hacker ist sehr guter nsa
hat er ist sehr gut vielleicht sind wir
auch gut in der zwischenzeit aber das
ist normales spionage da sein was es
schon immer gegeben hat nur nicht auf
der anderen seite mit dieser möglichkeit
der unterschied
und das sollten sie auch zur kenntnis
dass der unterschied ein handy abgehört
das ist natürlich ein gravierender
eingriff insbesondere gegen einen
verbündeten kriener letzte der das
rechtfertigen wird aber es ist ein
kategorischer unterschied ein handy
abzuhören oder ein paar kleine jahren
zulegen ein krankenhaus in la vie
zulegen das war die russin und lahm
legen heißt im fall dass menschen
persönlich in gefahr gebracht
das waren die russen das können wir
inzwischen alles nachweisen und zwar
können wir das nicht nur über starts
autoritäten nachweisen und übersetzer
und die verschiedenen staatsorgane die
die amerikaner dafür eingesetzt haben
sondern auch privat und
das meiste dieser nachverfolgung kommt
von amerikanischen inzwischen oder
europäischen zum teil auch
privatunternehmen
außerdem haben wir in der nato natürlich
den den cyber center of excellence die
eben auch quasi als zweiter
kontrollinstanz solche dinge
nachvollziehen und nachverfolgen können
und nehmen uns die letzten und da hat er
gut gekontert recht wenn wir uns allein
die letzten sechs wochen angucken ja von
den entwicklungen den aufdecken dem
aufdecken zu solarwinds der colonial
pipeline zu dem eingriff auf
hühnerfleisch firma so also da wird da
wird sehr viel muss mit muskeln gespielt
und ich gebe da recht das sind meiner
meinung nach keine zeichen für stärke
sondern ein ausdruck eines
verständnisses eine asymmetrie wir haben
einen herrn putin die einer der
einerseits angst hat vor den möglichen
kurzstrecken strategischen kapazitäten
der nato also daher dann immer schön
diese gefrorenen konflikte haben möchte
und umgekehrt sich weiterhin als großer
störenfried in der er in der
internationalen szene bewegen möchte
damit klar wird so er kann immer noch
taktisch die ellenbogen ausfahren aber
hat gegebenenfalls keinen langen
strategischen rahmen für diese aktion
das ist da würden sie sagen es ist
russland einfach eine größere gefahr als
man vorher gedacht hat es ist auf jeden
fall eine gefahr mit der man jetzt noch
aggressiver umgehen muss also wir haben
den nato-gipfel im voll auf dem
nato-gipfel hat jens stoltenberg gesagt
wir haben jetzt liegt jetzt auf der hand
dass die nato neues strategisches
konzept bekommt das auch überlegen wir
müssen über artikel 5 provisionen
nachdenken im sinne des des cyber rechts
und der cyber norm ist es richtig dass
das gespräch gesucht wird mit russland
die sich auch innerhalb der un bestimmte
dinge so gedreht haben dass die normen
für russland stimmen und nicht für den
rest der welt also da muss ganz schnell
nachgearbeitet werden wenn herr putin da
mitmacht dann kann man sich das alles
noch mal anschauen aber umgekehrt muss
die nato müssen die usa jetzt auch klare
kante zeigen
ok also das wäre ist eine klare rote
linie ich würde gerne noch zu einem
anderen punkt kommen der auch ganz
wichtig ist ich habe vorhin ja herrn gut
gefragt sagt die eu mit am tisch
sozusagen frau gesagt in china heute
auch mit am tisch weil das ist ja wenn
man sich überlegt wie diese wie die welt
sich entwickelt das dann hat man ja eher
den eindruck dass das von allen
das china wird ebenso mächtig und ist
die frage wie man damit umgeht welche
rolle spielt das heute also für
präsident putin tschuldigung für
präsident biden ist das wohl die
erklärung dafür warum er glaubt dass
präsident putin nicht an einem neuen
kalten krieg gelegen sein könne
ich zitiere mal aus der pressekonferenz
sagte biden dass russland ja eine
mehrere tausend kilometer lange grenze
mit china verbindet also ich glaube
beiden denkt dass das sozusagen russland
vielleicht dazu bringen könnte ein
bisschen mehr sich wieder richtung
westen oder richtung usa richtung europa
zu orientieren
in der pressekonferenz von präsident
putin ich denke jetzt gerade noch mal
kurz nach aber ich glaube da viel china
egal also das thema spielte zumindest
aus russischer sicht heute keine rolle
wenn dann also er zwischen den zeilen
wie sehr wie wichtig ist china für
russland bzw als motor auch um russland
doch wieder mit den usa irgendwie kinder
ist natürlich ein wichtiger nach dafür
für russland denn erstens mal was die
rohstoffe angeht erdgas erdöl nimmt
china relativ viel ab strategische
allianzen haben sie auch aber sie sind
noch nicht so ausgeprägt wie wir glaube
ich denken dass sie sind in dem
zusammenhang sie waren ja auch wirklich
auch mal feinde das doch mal noch nicht
mehr vergessen das ist zwar schon ein
bisschen länger her aber es wird sich
aus sagen sie ich glaube ich russland
hat momentan die chance zwischen nur
zwischen europa und china im grunde
genommen strategische interessen zu
vertreten
wie weit es gehen wird hängt sowohl von
uns ab und hängt sowohl allerdings auch
von den amerikanern gleichzeitig noch
mal hab ich glaube diese balance
hinzukriegen dass das im grunde genommen
nicht nur stärker in richtung china
getrieben mitglied bei uns bei uns ja
was kann die eu da tun und wie sehr ist
sie ist die frage wie wir mit china
umgehen auch eben entscheidend für das
miteinander von usa und russland ja also
für die eu ist es natürlich direkt an
das aus china als die vereinigten
staaten
das ist der punkt wo es auch einen
strategischen interessen unterschied
gibt
beide reden mittlerweile über china als
ein system rivalen das heißt die eben
nicht nur hervor dass es ein
wirtschaftlicher konkurrent ist sondern
dass es systemische unterschiede gibt so
wie eben auch im verhältnis zu russland
in bezug auf die menschenrechte
da sind amerika und europa bleibt aber
der eigentliche konflikt der amerikaner
mit china ist ein konflikt um die
globale vormachtstellung ein hegemonial
konflikt gu hat nicht das ziel eine
hegemoniale stellung zu erreichen
ihr ziel ist sie wer sich nicht ihnen
diesen konflikt so hineinziehen lassen
dass sie am ende ihre eigenen interessen
nicht mehr richtig vertreten kann also
sie werden nicht mehr wissen wer oder
die und die frage ist wie groß der
spielraum bleibt in diesem konflikt für
die eu um ihre eigene position zu
behaupten
die entwicklung der letzten monate war
sicherlich so dass die eu stärker an die
seite amerikas gerückt ist was meiner
sicht vor allem deshalb weil die
chinesen die sanktionen die die europäer
verhängt haben sehr moderate sanktionen
wegen der menschenrechtsverletzungen an
den figuren ich formuliere das jetzt
bewusst vorsichtig mit einer eskalation
beantwortet haben die deren ergebnisse
war dass die europäer und die amerikaner
hier einen neuen schulterschluss
gefunden haben obwohl wie gesagt es in
der sache da doch hier einige wichtige
strategische unterschiede gibt raub
lieber erstmal inwieweit spielt die
frage nach der vormachtstellung
inwieweit ist dass der treiber dass man
sagt wir müssen auf jeden fall immer die
nummer eins in der welt bleiben für die
amerikaner die amerikaner so wir haben
jetzt ein anderes führungsverständnis
der amerikaner also wenn das vorher war
unbedingt nummer eins ist jetzt die
erkenntnis wir müssen zusammen mit dem
restlichen westen der nicht geografisch
topografischen orientieren ist das sehen
wir an der ganz starken ausrichtung
dieser administration natürlich auch
erst mal nach indien australien
südkorea und japan teils kurz also frau
merkel fährt jetzt im juli hin aber ist
die dritte staatschef in die im weißen
haus ankommt also das ist schon dieser
gedanke amerika geht glaube ich auch
unter dieser administration offen damit
um dass sie nicht irgendwie in dem sinne
unangefochten die nummer eins sondern
eben nur die nummer 1 weil sie den
schirm der der allianzen und der
verbündeten haben also wenn sie ganz
klar nicht mehr im amt ist genau also
ich meine das ist theoretisch der
außenpolitische das ist der seit über 70
jahren getragene außenpolitische duktus
amerikas aber dieser durch diesen
einschnitt von trump ist das muss das
noch mal ganz klar gesagt werden und es
hängt an dem dann der die beständigkeit
des pax americana eben dass diese ganze
länder zusammen gehalten können also
dieser ab 1
wie wird das dann in amerika sind ja wer
mal für eine frau gar die erzählt wie
wichtig dieses treffen putin in russland
gesehen wird und wie wichtig das für ihn
ist für seine in kunststoff standing ist
das denn für ihr es für beiden auch
wichtig oder interessiert ist nein das
ist enorm wichtig also es wurde jetzt ja
in jedem in jeder minute
herr niemann haben wir vorhin in den
tagesthemen noch mal gesehen da wurde
jede kleine minutiöse bewegung der
beiden analysiert denn da sind alte
feindbilder dabei aber da wird auch ganz
klar der vergleich gesucht mit donald
trump da haben ja auch seine
parteikollegen nachdem helsinki gipfel
gesagt er ist der amerikanische
präsident vorgeführt worden nämlich will
noch eine ganz kurze sache sagen so
china ich glaube das zeug für mich
wiederum auch von taktischen denken dass
vladimir putin es geht er ist ein ein
taktiker wie er im buche steht das
ausspielen des verhältnisses zu der
türkei das ausspielen das feld das ist
so china die gemeinsame militärübungen
das ist alles hoch ins ballett aber zwei
dinge die dann eben noch mal wichtig
sind auch die herr gewaltig implizit
schon ansprach china und russland stehen
trotzdem vor den türen europas nämlich
in der arktis und das kam noch einmal
ganz klar auch in der pressekonferenz
von beiden wurde das noch mal deutlich
gemacht aber das sehen wir auch erst
einmal genau und das sehen wir aber eben
auch in der nato und in den überlegungen
der eu also man kann sich auch diese die
sich überspitzt das jetzt machen sagt
kümmel aber diese annäherung china
russland das müssen die eu und die nato
ganz klar im auge behalten nicht weil
sich das in weiter ferne
spielen könnte sondern weil diese
verquickung der militärischen macht
russlands die näher dran hieß an europa
und der wirtschaftlichen weltmacht china
ist die uns dann doch brandgefährlich
werden könnte wegen der verschiedenen
abhängigkeiten gekoppelt natürlich
schwerwiegende folgen haben könnten für
die eu und für die nato
und da ist also schon immer zu sehen
dass dieser ganze problem prozess
gemeinsam und gemeinsam mit den
amerikanern in enger absprache behandelt
werden es gab auf der pressekonferenz
zitierte eine journalistin ihre
neunjährige tochter die die mutter dann
gefragt hat warum musste da eigentlich
hin was ist denn da so wichtig an diesem
treffen und dann wurde noch einmal auf
das wort des weltfriedens bemüht dass es
wichtig ist dass da zwei weil die ja von
diesen großen mächten eben an einem
tisch sitzen weil sie mir natürlich auch
um die abrüstung den vielleicht jetzt in
der schlussrunde noch mal sehr gut gab
wie was würden sie sagen wo geht das
jetzt weiterhin was nehmen wir mit jetzt
aus diesem punkt ist es sagen wir mal ja
auch in richtung abrüstung doch das
richtige zeichen gewesen dass wir sagen
das hat die welt ein bisschen
friedlicher gemacht oder könnte die welt
friedlicher man ist ja danach heute
mehrfach gefragt worden und im grunde
hat er gesagt wenn sie am ende kommt es
ja nicht auch das an was man sagt in
einer pressekonferenz sondern wie man
dann handelt und seine politik gestaltet
deswegen können wir das heute abend
nicht sagen was man aber sagen kann und
das fand ich bemerkenswert genug ist
dass beide tatsächlich weil sie das
stetig von abrüstung genannt haben über
abrüstungsfragen gesprochen haben und
wie beiden hinterher sagte im detail und
daran kann sich natürlich einige
hoffnung nun auch anfangs so wir haben
nicht also viel zeit frage was ist ihre
hoffnung
also beide scheinen ja vereinbart zu
haben dass jetzt über rüstungskontrolle
erstmal auf ebene der außenministerien
gesprochen wird und das dann also
wirklich verhandlungen starten sollen
das ist natürlich auf jeden fall ein
gutes signal
allerdings muss man immer im hinterkopf
behalten mit wem verhandelt man da und
wie zuverlässig ist dann dieser
vertragspartner auch und auch danach
wurde heute mehrfach gefragt also wie
kann man sozusagen mit wladimir putin
verhandeln und wie kann man sich dann
darauf verlassen oder wie kann man ihnen
sozusagen wieder dazu bringen ein
verlässlicher politiker zu sein
und da habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine
antwort gehört wieder von dem einen noch
von dem anderen der beiden hat ja betont
wie wichtig ist dass man sich wirklich
persönlich trifft man sich auch in die
augen schaute ganz kurz noch zum
geländes gehört es ist es gibt ein
schönes sprichwort von leo tolstoi und
er sagt alle wollen die welt verändern
nur keiner will sich selbst verändern
er müsste sich verändert ich glaube
america first müsste ich auch verändern
denn der american league selbst
journalisten den der als besondere
mission für die welt kennen hat ziemlich
viel und ritten bisher geschaffen haben
also die amerikaner haben ganz klar ein
auge darauf weil die russen ja jetzt
gerade ihre ganze nuklearwaffen
nachgerüstet haben und was passiert wenn
man nicht miteinander redet und im
direkten austausch steht in der
diplomatie ist es können missverständnis
zu passieren uns können unfälle
passieren und dass wir da jetzt gerade
an einer brandgefährlichen stelle sind
weil die russen eben völlig neue
waffensysteme haben in ihrem nuklearen
arsenale und die amerikaner noch nicht
das bringt eine dringlichkeit auf den
teppich also wie herr geiger sagte die
nächsten paar monate und wochen werden
es zeigen
aber da werden wir genau hinschauen
müssen okay wenn man genau hinschauen
ganz herzlichen dank in allen drogba
nach genfer coach von brüssel herrscht
hier und ihnen vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und jetzt geht es weiter bei
phoenix der tag und dann schauen wir da
natürlich auch noch mal ausführlich auf
die pressekonferenzen und thomas bade
führt sie durch die sendung ist dann
tschüss
[Musik]